this is a production of cornell
university
and welcome everybody to the uh fall
2020
seminar series online this is really
exciting i'm
particularly excited for our seminar
speaker to kick off with apples as we
get into the apple harvest and
um today's seminar speaker is sean miles
from
dalhousie university in nova scotia
i first learned about sean from his
research
in apple genetics and while i was
working on the horticultural side he's
been working a lot on the genetic side
we had a lot of
overlapping interests and that really
became
apparent in our conversation just before
this seminar today but uh in doing a
little bit of research on sean
it's pretty interesting and it's always
really fascinating to learn about
people's academic histories and
really uh sean's training was in human
genetics and he was studying
the populations of different
people around the world he was working
at the max planck
institute in germany and actually
was working on some of the earliest
sequencing fast sequencing machines and
being able to
process through many samples and doing
things like um snip
arrays for for humans to understand how
different populates and people moved
around the world and then got
into grapes basically because he fell in
love with a winemaker
and figured that if they're gonna find a
place to live together
um he better figure out something that
he can do where
she's gonna be based because grapes can
only be grown in so many locations
throughout the world
and got into apples later in his
um academic interests so really
fascinating and
deep um research history that that sean
has
as we do for all of our seminar speakers
one interesting fact and even though all
of these things i mentioned already were
quite interesting
i asked sean if there was something he'd
like to share and so
the interesting and and not well-known
fact about sean miles is that he can tap
dance
and so um you can think about him tap
dancing
while he does his seminar today so i'll
pass it off to sean at this point
again if anybody has questions for sean
during the seminar
feel free to put them in the chat and
we'll address them during the q
a period great thanks greg
i'm just uh if anyone has any problems
uh hearing me then they can put
something into the chat there to let
them know and thanks for the
introduction i was just thinking you
know what it actually would make the
seminar a lot more interesting if i was
tap dancing
uh while doing a talk about uh genetics
uh but
uh but i would need a little more
practice i think so i didn't really
quite uh
plan on that but i'll keep it in mind
for next time so i'll expect another
invitation
thanks for having me this is uh this is
really great and i wanted to mention too
uh i'm going to share my screen here i
think right
i think this is how this works so that
if i pop this
up i believe everybody should be able to
see that great
um so i did want to mention uh you know
you talked about this uh
sort of uh circuitous route towards uh
agriculture and and it's worth since
there are many students uh listening in
i hope
uh that uh you know uh often it's a
little bit daunting when
uh showing up somewhere and getting into
something new uh and when you're getting
into a new subject area
and i wanna assure you you know i
started i did my undergraduate degree
with a major in english literature
and uh my master's in phd in human
genetics and didn't start looking at
plants until my post-doc
and so um you know
these sorts of uh circuitous routes can
happen in life and
there's lots of chance meetings along
the way and if you put your head down
and focus on doing good science and
doing good work
then lots of things are possible and so
i thought i'd mention that because i
know that
often in fact every time i took a new
position
somewhere uh at each institution that i
went to
i would feel completely overwhelmed when
i first got there like i did
during my postdoc at cornell i arrived
in ed buckler's lab
who was talking a million miles a minute
about corn and i knew nothing
about anything anyone was talking about
in lab meetings as a postdoc
you know you kind of feel like you might
you should probably know something
uh so that feeling of being overwhelmed
and being stressed out and like feeling
like
you're an imposter and you're in the
wrong place i i can assure you that
it does uh subside with the years and
that uh
that's my little piece of advice for all
the students getting in and shuffling
around into their different uh
departments and different endeavors
along their career paths so
uh thank you very much for having me the
first thing i'd like to start with is
that
to show you where i am uh so i'm in nova
scotia canada
up here in the uh sort of northeast of
uh of the north american continent uh
out on that little peninsula
and it's a beautiful place to be and i
thought i'd just describe a little bit
where i am here this is nova scotia
there's nothing of the us on here maine
is just the west of new brunswick here
but we are in i'm located in the
annapolis valley i work for
dalhousie university but i actually work
out of a federal research station
so it's kind of like cornell professors
who are co-located up in geneva new york
uh i actually work out of a federal
research station here
in kentville nova scotia up here in what
we call the annapolis valley in the
annapolis valley
uh contains about we grow about 10 of
the of canada's apple production
um so it's a very small area but it's
sizeable uh in terms of its contribution
to apples and canada
and there's only about a million people
who live in nova scotia overall so it's
mostly rural
and the the main city is halifax we
grow in our little valley here grow
almost uh you know
the majority of the food grown in nova
scotia
especially all the fruit crops so we
grow apples and and
pears and plums and peaches and more and
more grapes there's a
growing wine industry so it's not unlike
upstate new york
uh in uh in its growing conditions and
this in the sorts of things that we're
growing
and it's a beautiful place to visit and
when all this coveted stuff is over
you're more than welcome to come and
have a
have a glance i do we don't often get
visitors coming up to talk about science
so it's a real pleasure if you do
so if you were ever thinking of having a
visit up to the east coast of canada
please do get in touch and i'd be happy
to show you around
um and it's a beautiful place to come
and eat apples and drink cider too of
course
um so i did want to mention you know
during my postdoc
when i was at cornell there was a real
interest in
in these in using modern genomics
technologies and the emerging genomic
technologies to
to characterize the usda's gene banks or
germplasm collections
and my postdoc project under uh the
supervision of ed buckler was to uh
characterize
develop a snip array and characterize
the uh
the usda grape germplasm collection in
collaboration with the usda researchers
up in
geneva new york and also part of the
collection is down in davis california
and it was a wonderful opportunity i
felt really fortunate to be able to do
that work
and i've moved on now started a position
up here in canada
and in our experience
dealing with the usda germplasm
collection of course is that it was not
planted for the purposes of doing
genetic
mapping work necessarily it's planted as
a gene bank in order to preserve and
maintain diversity
of course that often means that the
plants are planted at different times
perhaps on different root stocks
maintained by different people and the
data is collected
at different times of the year and in a
different way than you might want to
collect the data for the purposes of
genetic mapping
and so when i started my position here
in canada
i made a special request to the usda to
that was accepted fortunately to
actually
make a copy essentially of the usda
apple germplasm collection up in nova
scotia which we now call canada's apple
biodiversity collection
it contains as many of the malice
domesticasts of the domesticated apple
and its wild primary wild ancestor
malice of versi
and so we didn't take all the other wild
species and incorporate it in here
because the purpose of this map this
population was really to
plant it out specifically for the
purposes of genetic mapping and doing
genome-wide association studies
so we planted this out uh each of these
uh varieties out in duplicate well we
grafted them all to m9 rootstock in 2011
and then in 2013 we planted it we ended
up with 1113 different accessions
planted in duplicate with czech
varieties
that are planted throughout so that you
can control for the spatial
effects in the orchard and so in total
it's 2
354 trees and that's uh
that includes a lot of that most of that
material is from the usda but there's
also advanced breeding lines from
canada's apple breeding program and some
other stuff we had hanging around in
nova scotia that we threw in there
so uh if you're ever interested in
seeing this so what we've been doing to
give you an idea
i'm not going to talk about this
collection today this is really the
genetic mapping work i'm going to talk
more about the evolutionary work that
we've done based on the usda collection
but what we've really focused on here in
nova scotia with this
apple biodiversity collection is to try
to get as much
phenotype data as we can on a budget
of course and it's very time consuming
and expensive to do as many of you are
aware to collect traits across an
orchard like this
and so we've made use of barcode
scanners where we can
to speed that up and it's a herculean
effort really to do over a thousand
varieties and harvest them all at the
right times too
because they're all developing at
different rates and put them through
you know and collect the data that you'd
like so i made a little video here and
i'm hoping this is going to work and
we'll see
but this is one of the devices we use
called the pimpernell
that does automated uh weighing of every
apple
and then the so the first step is the
weight
weighing right there and then the next
step it goes up into a penetrometer
there's an automated penetrometer that
will take a firmness measure then it
shoots that apple into a chute
that then gets squished and the apple
gets squished up and it does
automatically it takes the uh the
um the acidity and the soluble solids
and so you get that automatically
directly into the spreadsheet no writing
down data and copying it back into excel
files and so on
uh and we made that trying to find ways
of making that
data uh acquisition process as efficient
as possible
and one of the other little devices is
pretty nifty because we want to get
color
and shape we take a picture of all the
apples going through
we you call this little device the
snapple because it takes snapshots of
every apple
uh and you go and uh put the apple in
and it takes a snapshot and
links it to the id and it goes right up
into a a little uh
drive there we put this together with
some engineering students at the
university
and so that's sped things up and we've
we've got a decent data set from our
apple biodiversity collection since many
of those are actually
apples that are found at the usda
collection in geneva
that the data set that we will will come
to publish here shortly will be
you know it'll be publicly available and
available to anyone who's
also studying these apples in geneva new
york so i encourage anybody
who is doing work in apples and is
looking for
sort of a comprehensive evaluation of
phenotype data that they might
like to link to the data that they've
got and the genotype data is going to be
all available as well
i think we've got about quarter million
markers now genotyped in the entire
collection so if you'd
um we're really keen to know of other
people who are doing
uh this kind of work on those same
varieties and since they're genetically
identical but just planted in different
spots
if you're up in the geneva collection
doing something interesting then uh
feel free to reach out and we're happy
to come up with a way
of of helping out your study and perhaps
adding some data to it that will be
uh useful to you okay
so today i'm going to talk about some
data that we've collected on the usda
collection which is
far overdue to be published but uh it
should come out
relatively soon this is work that was
led by two postdocs in my lab zoe
mijikovsky and kyle gardner
and some help from a phd student sophie
watts and my main collaborator june song
from agriculture in agri-food canada
here who helped out
and this was a project that was led in
collaboration with the usda
uh led by gangnam song in geneva
so the usda apple germplasm collection
is is fantastic it's really
a real showcase uh germ uh
gene bank from the usda in terms of its
breadth and depth
uh certainly the number of countries
represented in terms of
where these apples are coming from is
enormous
you can see a lot of them are from the
united states 228
uh but you know there's a hundred
varieties from the united kingdom and a
good representation from central asia
which is
sort of the the original home of the the
apple so where it originated so
those progenitor apples and so this
gives you an idea of the
of the breadth of that collection and
what we did uh
is we collected genotyping by sequencing
data i'm going to talk about some
genetic data that we collected from this
entire collection
we ran 42 lanes of illumina high seeks
so generated
7.8 uh 7.9 billion hundred base pair
reads
from 1949 accessions from that
collection
so i'm not going to talk today about
what we did with the other uh
members of the malice species uh that
are that have not really contributed or
contributed only
um recently really to apple breeding and
apple development to modern cultivars
i'm focusing mainly today uh exclusively
today on the
variety on the species thought to have
contributed to
modern day apples so
we've used these data already actually
in a previous publication to do
a genome-wide association study to
perform some genetic mapping
where we take the data from usda grin
database
and so we didn't collect any phenotype
data ourselves we just used existing
historical phenotype data from the
database
and linked it to the uh the gbs data the
genotyping by sequencing data
and that resulted in about at that time
when we were
doing fairly simple bioinformatics with
these data
we had 8 000 snips or single nucleotide
polymorphisms these are the markers that
we get from the sequence data
so we only ended up with 8 000 snips and
some very messy phenotype data i must
admit
from the usda grid database often things
are scored as
you know the apple is either soft or
it's hard but not
a quantification of the actual firmness
of the apple for instance
or the apple is either early or it's
late but not the actual date it was
harvested on
and so on but despite that you know even
with uh
some relatively noisy phenotype data you
can
you can catch the lowest hanging fruit
and we did in that publication
uh demonstrate that we identified the
main locus underlying
firmness that we've done some subsequent
work on and believe that it is a
very important for ripening apple
ripening so
i'm not going to talk about that work
today but i do want to point out that
it's really great using these genotyping
by sequencing data
you know or any of this next generation
dna sequence data compared to
microarrays
when you're using a microarray you you
run it once and
and the data you've got is what you've
got but it turns out with sequence data
there's always a new algorithm coming
out you know
every year to be able to point at your
original sequence data to extract more
of that data and so you can ex we point
to
we've developed we spent a couple of
years developing imputation algorithms
and genotype calling
algorithms that would be more suitable
for
non-model organisms like the apple that
have a poor
relatively poor reference genome where
the order of the markers can't be
is not always really reliable where you
can't really phase haplotypes because of
rapid linkage equilibrium
decay and where the the existing genome
sequences are kind of a poor quality
um and and they're highly highly
heterozygous
so they're uh those present some
challenges for genotype calling and
generating a really good
genetic data set and so uh we worked
quite hard on this and developed
our last our most recent imputation
algorithm link computer
um and with lane computer we've we've
actually managed to generate a lot more
snips in the present
presentation that i'm doing today uh and
the paper that we've got submitted
we've got about 20 to 30 000 snips so
you more than double the number of snips
you got from your first try
but since then we've actually tweaked
things a little bit and we're up over
200 000 snips now
with the exact same data that we used to
only get 8 000 snips from
so again with microarrays you get what
you get
but with the sequence data there are
ways of using that missing data that's
in there
using patterns from the existing data to
fill in missing data quite a bit better
we find and that's been a real uh real
benefit to us
so uh just keep that in mind in that
link computer algorithm for people who
are working on non-model organisms and
collecting genetic data and they wish to
fill in their missing data link computer
is great because it
it allows you to say for example you
know i'm okay with a 10
genotyping error rate if i can get a
quarter million snips
or you can say no no i want really high
quality i only want
one percent error rate well then you
might only get 25 000 snips
and it allows the user to decide what
error rate they wish to accept
and therefore how many markers you're
willing to get so if you're on a fishing
expedition and you're doing some genetic
mapping
uh you may want to make it uh pretty
loose and have
large numbers of markers with you know
quite a bit of error
because you can always go back to the
markers that are associated and go check
to see whether they're real
on the other hand if you're doing some
kind of population genetic analysis and
you want
reliable marker data you may want to be
more strict so it allows the user to
decide that
okay so i'm just going to get into some
of the questions that we wish to answer
with these genetic data and it's well
known from several publications and from
lots of work that's even been done on
the on the phenotype level
uh and just traditional botany that the
the primary progenitor of the uh modern
apple that you would see in the grocery
store
is comes from a species called
malaceversii which is
uh still found in the forests of
kazakhstan and the tianshen mountains
along the
uh very close to the border of china and
so here you see malice version here
printed in
right in the middle of uh kazakhstan and
that this
it's believed that this male then
as humans moved along with humans
uh over to europe and
there it um had some introgression from
malice silvestris which is another
malice species it's a wild european crab
apple
very small astringent and bitter and
the degree of that integration is still
under debate and
there's been some conflicting findings
in the literature so one of the things
that we can do with our data since we
have some malice silvestris in the
collection and some malice of
ci and lots of modern apples we can ask
ourselves the question of
what do uh what do the relationships
look like between
these various species so
here are the sample sizes across the top
for this particular analysis is 749
malice domestica so those are the what
you would consider
uh dessert apples and cider apples
modern varieties and so on
uh 115 malic civersii those are from
kazakhstan
and 11 malicious from europe
and those so you can see if we run a
principal components analysis if we take
those
20 to 30 000 snips and we plug them into
principal components what principle
components
allows us to do is visualize the
relationships among all the individuals
in two dimensions you have 20 to 30 000
snips
and you want to visualize how everyone
is related
essentially pc1 here is like shooting a
regression line through a 20 to 30 000
dimensional space
and uh and then pc2 is then an another
orthogonal kind of regression line
through that space
and so it's capturing as much of the
variation in the data as you can and you
can see pc one
accounts for about six six and a half
percent of the data six point seven four
percent of the data
so what you're looking at here gives you
a visualization of the relationships
among individuals and what you see
the squares on the right hand side of
the plot those are all malice
sylvester's those are the european wild
crab apple on the right hand side
you can see that there's two groups of
them and in fact the one in the top
they're from germany and the one down
below or from further in eastern europe
so there's a little bit of structure
within the population but we're really
just concerned with pc1 here and how
very easily the genetic data separate
those malice sylvester samples
represented by the squares on the right
with the triangles on the left hand side
which belong to malice civersia
so it's very easy with these genetic
data to pull these two two species apart
now if we want to know where the malice
domestica lie
and how they're related to these two
groups then what we do is we
project those malice domestica onto
these axes
and there's a there's a way of doing
this uh using standard
principal components analysis to project
those samples on
i've colored those dots either they're
gray if we don't know exactly what
they're used for
or if they're cider apples they're in
orange
and if they're dessert mainly what we
call dessert apples or the ones
eating apples the ones you find in the
grocery store or other some of them are
labeled as cooking in grin
but they're essentially not cider apples
they're in blue
so you can see that but basically you
form a cloud
right in the middle right between malice
version silvestris about 50 50. so
the conclusion there would be that they
share about half their ancestry from the
original ancestor melissa versailles
about half from al-silvestris
however i'd be cautious about putting
too much into that interpretation giving
the number of markers we have
and the number of malicious samples we
have which is only 11.
and there are some more studies coming
out that we know of here in the near
future that are doing whole genome
sequencing which will be able to better
answer those questions
um but despite that one of the most one
of the most interesting things here
is that those two clouds of orange and
blue dots don't actually
line up completely the orange dots tend
to be pulled over
further to the right and the blue dots
further to the left and that's
demonstrated here in panel b
where if you look at the pc-1 values of
cider apples
you can see that they are significantly
greater than the the
pc-1 values of the other or desert
apples
and so it appears from our analysis that
regardless of what the proportions are
of the ancestry between sylvesterous and
cervici
that cider apples tend to they appeared
to derive more of their ancestry from
malice silvestris the european crab
apple
than do uh dessert apples and this makes
good sense
uh in a way because the malice of estrus
apples are known to be
very astringent and bitter and have a
lot of tannin and are acidic
and share some of those characteristics
that cider apples
that are desirable in cider apples and
that are less desirable in an eating
novel
and so it may be the case that some of
those desirable characteristics from
cider apples
are actually introduction events from uh
malice silvestris we weren't able really
to do a
a piece by piece genome analysis to see
where those introductions might occur
given the snip density that we have
but i'm sure that's coming in the future
too with future data
another question we can ask is what
regions of the genome appear to have
been under selection during
domestication so what are the
what are the regions of the genome that
really are most differentiated between
malice domestica or the the apples that
you might see on the grocery store shelf
versus the wild ancestors that are
growing in the forest of kazakhstan
and to do this what you can do is
calculate fst which is a measure of
allele frequency difference
between the two populations between
malice domestic and male subversion
and fst is a very simple measure if if
the allele frequency at a particular
snip
is exactly the same between the two
populations you get an fst of zero
if they are if it's a fixed difference
if all the domestica
are homozygous a a and all the at that
locus and
and all the maliceversii are homozygous
tt for the other allele then that's a
fixed difference and they'd have an fst
of one
you can see that there are regions of
the genome that are approaching an fst
of one each of the dots on this plot
represents one of the snips that we've
genotyped
and the horizontal red line represents
the five percent threshold genome-wide
so any dots above that line
are within the top five percent most
extreme fst values in the genome
and what we expect when selection
happens at on a particular at a
particular locus is the markers there
they will be they'll be driven to high
frequency very very quickly over time
and there'll be a large fst value
between domestica and cervici
so we're taking a look at all those dots
across the top and thinking okay are are
those lying in any genes that
are particularly important well there's
a somewhat orthogonal analysis you can
do here to determine whether it's really
selection or not
because you can make an fst distribution
from two populations when no selection
has happened
and there's still going to be five
percent of your markers that are going
to be within the top five percent
there's always a top five percent to
every distribution so we throw another
analysis of this called
xpeh so when a marker rises in frequency
very quickly due to selection
instead of just genetic drift then what
happens is
recombination doesn't have enough time
to go and break down
the haplotype that's around it and what
you end up with is a very long haplotype
that's homozygous
in the population and that can be
calculated as this statistic called
cross-population extended haplotype
homozygosity or the xpeh
and that's shown there on the y-axis on
this bottom panel
and each of the dots again here
represent one marker that we've
genotyped across the genome
and its position along that axis shows
whether it is
whether it shows extended haplotype
homozygosity
in malice domestica so here we're we're
uh
checking to see look for evidence of
selection within the domesticated apple
so dots that lie above that horizontal
red line
represent potential targets of selection
during domestication and breeding
now ideally in these circumstances you
see a great big peak that overlaps with
fst and with xphhh
and right underneath that peak you look
into the genome browser and you see
the name of a gene that is really
obvious and then you go and you look at
it in detail and
you characterize it in a tomato and you
throw it at nature genetics and you get
published well it doesn't turn out that
way for us
i'm afraid um with no smoking guns i
mean you look at the gene list and it's
lots of different genes
uh and so one of the things you can do
when you don't have any real
great candidate genes for domestication
between the domesticated apple and the
and its ancestor you know it's worth
keeping in mind that when we look at the
ancestor of the domesticated apple they
often really
look the same too like they look very
similar cevici
apples sometimes look like something you
could find in the grocery store
whereas another anim with in other
animals and other plants when you look
at the wild ancestor
and you look at the the modern cultivar
it's really obvious it's like oh okay
it's it's seed shattering or it's you
know ear development or it's something
and in apple it's really not entirely
evident what genes we would look at
if we were going to look at something
that's been under selection
uh so we don't have really good a priori
ideas about what they should be but when
we
so one of the things you can do you can
take a look at all of the snips that
overlap
within the top within the top five
percent for both fst
and xph those represent potential
targets of selection and you can look at
whether uh genes that are within a
certain distance i think 50 kb we chose
and then you can see whether those genes
are enriched in any particular
biological category are they involved
are they enriched in some uh function
and when we do a gene ontology
enrichment analysis we do find these
three things that are
enriched for these genes that have
appeared to have been
that show signatures of selection in uh
malice domestica
and that's target of rapamycin signaling
cellular response to phosphate
starvation and cellular response to
stress
it's been suggested before too in a
previous publication that
uh the the targets of selection and the
domesticated apple are
are related to adaptation to new
environments as they've moved
uh from the chenchon mountains to new
environments
and uh our data are consistent with that
hypothesis
but we don't have any really great
smoking guns and single genes that we
have a great story about right now in
terms of
domestication and apple
but we can do the exact same analysis
actually by comparing dessert apples
with cider apples so
there are 69 apples in the collection
for which we have genotype data and good
phenotype data that
are are characterized as cider apples
and
and these are so in some cases they're
characterized as both these are the ones
that are characterized as just
cider apples and dessert apples we have
288 here's a comparison
comparing fst between dessert and cider
apples you can see the fst values are
generally lower they don't go all the
way up to one the y axis there is only
going up to 0.5 so they're more closely
related to each other
than malice domestic ml cervici that
makes good sense
and what we see what we see here is that
the same kind of analysis can be done
but in this case we can look at
uh genes that appear to have been under
selection according to this xph
statistic
in dessert apples those would be found
above the dotted red line
here in the in uh below and then those
that are appear to
uh carry a signature of selection
insider apple so what may have been
uh selected for uh in cider apple
development and cider breeding
cider apple breeding and again we don't
find any single genes that stand out as
being
the sort of smoking gun in this analysis
but when we do a gene ontology
enrichment analysis we do find
that flavonoid biosynthesis genes are
enriched in the regions of high fst and
high xph
in the desert apples while malate
transport
is enriched for cider apples now we know
that cider apples in general are more
acidic and malate transport genes are
involved in the production of malic acid
so it's very possible that this is
something that's been selected for in
cider apples and flavonoid biosynthesis
flavonoids are
are are molecules that are that
contribute to the tannin and the
mouthfeel and the
uh and the the polyphenols in an apple
and the uh and a lot of the um
greg can help me on all this stuff i
think he knows a lot more about this
than i do
but uh the flavonoid biosynthesis and
dessert apples one might think well
i don't think you know in terms of the
difference between dessert and cider
apples dessert apples probably
have fewer polyphenols than cider apples
and it may be exactly that it may be
that there's been active selection
against polyphenols and antioxidants
and in fact we have some orthogonal data
here to speak to this this is
uh the phenolic content in apple
varieties
compared to their year of release so
these are all dessert apples
uh that have a year of release
associated with them
and you can see that uh it's the only
thing we've found actually that's
correlated with year of release we've
looked at soluble solids and size and
assets and everything and the only thing
that seems to be really robustly
correlated with
with year of release this is the year
that the apple cultivar was released to
the public
as you know after breeding is phenolic
content seems to have gone down you can
see that in the year 2000 the average
uh for apples that were released after
the year 2000 their phenolic content is
on average i think something like 30
percent lower than things that were
released before 1900
so uh it does suggest that perhaps there
has been
active selection by breeders for reduced
polyphenol content
in dessert apples making them uh less
astringent less bitter and less tannic
and that kind of thing so this is worthy
of future investigation
but undoubtedly the strongest signature
of selection that we find in the genome
is for color
so this on the top panel here you see
the result of a g
wasp for color with these data so in g
watts we take a look at every marker and
it's
the strength of its correlation with a
trait and in this
case the apples are characterized in the
usda grin database as either red or
green
or red or not red i think and so we've
we've actually just done an analysis
here of red versus green apples
and when we compare red versus green
apples and we calculate and we do a g
wasp where we're looking for the
correlation between each marker and that
color
the strength of the correlation is
indicated by the height of the dot on
that
y-axis so that y-axis is the minus log
10-p-value
of the strength of the association and
again that horizontal red line that you
see across here
that represents our significance
threshold so dots that are above that
uh we're going to consider significant
in this analysis after correcting for
multiple comparisons so you can see that
there's
one very strong peak here on chromosome
9
and that's unsurprising it overlaps with
the red te this
transposable element that we believe is
responsible for the
red color in apples that's been
described in another manuscript
here um and it sits in the middle of a
mib
transcription factor which is known to
be involved in anthocyanin
synthesis so this this makes good sense
our
we're picking up the locus using g wasps
this isn't surprising
there are some little helicopter what we
call helicopter hits flying around here
on the outside
turns out those actually are not other
loci
involved in color but they're mismapped
snips they actually belong on chromosome
9 but the genome is often wrong and so
you end up with these little dots around
the genome and they they're just in the
wrong place
so we really have one single locus very
strong major effect locus control in
color
and if we look at the xphhh again and we
compare
red to green apples it turns out that
red apples have
a very long extended haplotype around
there and they're often homozygous for
this haplotype
so we see this extended haplotype
homozygosity this very strong signature
of selection around that nib locus
suggesting that breeders over the last
we can't really say how many years but
certainly over the last 700 years have
been
selecting for redder and redder apples
we can do similarly you can think of
other phenotypes that uh
that may have been desirable during
apple improvement
and that may have been targeted and that
we may be able to find signatures for in
the genome and one of those might be
firmness
now here we're presenting just firmness
at harvest and i understand you know
firmness at harvest is one thing but
firmness after a few months of storage
is a completely other thing so how much
do you soften
so i'm not looking at softening here i'm
really just looking at firmness
and so firmness at harvest if you run
this uh
in the usda grin database it's
characterized as either firm or soft
so we take those two and we run a gwas
with our markers this is with 8 000
markers in a previous publication
and we find this again this is each
marker and its strength of its
correlation the higher on the y axis
the stronger the correlation and the
dotted line here is the significance
threshold and we find this one hit
on chromosome three and it falls within
knack 18.1 and nac
is a transcription factor that's known
to be involved in the ripening process
of lots of organisms in fact it's
homologue in
tomato is the nor gene and the nor
mutant in tomato is a well-known mutant
which is a knockout of the nora gene
that inhibits ripening in the tomato
and so and in other organisms we know
that nack genes are involved in ripening
so this is an excellent
candidate gene this is this is one of
these cases where we did have a smoking
gun
you know we do the analysis we find the
gene it looks like knack 18.1 we've done
it again
many times it's been verified in other
collections but certainly
when we do it in our whole apple
biodiversity collection with 863
varieties
you can see that it comes out that same
snip actually comes out as the top snip
you can see how much more power you have
when you measure
firmness here uh using a digital
penetrometer
and uh measure the actual firmness and
get a quantitative measure and you have
you know four times the sample size or
twice the sample size maybe
so you can see that knack really comes
out very very strong here
the question is does is there any
signature of selection around that locus
is there any evidence that there's been
selection for firmness
during apple improvement and the
question is well
kind of maybe so the firm versus soft
apples that we do with our 20 to 30 000
snips in this particular paper that i'm
presenting here
in this analysis we see that knack 18.1
that
green dot again that's the marker in the
middle of knack 18.1
you can see it does not go above the
line and is not significant in this
analysis
okay despite the fact that we know now
that we've done this
in other populations and the the folks
in denmark did it
uh an analysis and they also found knack
18.1 associated with it another european
group has
we know that that's really a snip that
should be
associated significantly with firmness
but
this is a good lesson for people when
they're doing genetic mapping is like
where did that horizontal red line come
from who decided that it was going to be
there
the fact of the matter is is in this
analysis we have 20 to 30 000 snips so
when we correct for multiple comparisons
that red line goes up
so the the the criteria become more
stringent
if you have fewer markers the red line
goes down
but if knack 18.1 is part of the marker
set in one analysis it's significant
you add markers to your analysis all of
a sudden it's not significant anymore
so it doesn't mean significant
statistical significance with these
somewhat arbitrary thresholds it's very
different from biological significance
it's worth keeping in mind that just
because knack 18 1.1 falls below the
horizontal line in this analysis doesn't
mean that it's not biologically relevant
because we have evidence from other
studies that it is
so where does it fall in terms of its
signature of selection in terms of its
haplotype homozygosity you can see here
on the bottom
panel that green dot is the snip that
lies within knack 18.1
and it is not within the top five
percent
of snip's genome wide but it's within
the top 5.2
of snip's genome-wide so you're in one
of these situations again where
it sits right around the threshold of
significance that you've
made for yourself uh and so that
the the evidence is a little bit
ambivalent
so uh it's worth pointing these things
out because sometimes you're not you
wish the analyses would come out and
provide you smoking guns every time but
it doesn't always work that way
uh so we do find some evidence for
selection for firmness but certainly
future studies are going to be required
in order to validate that
so perhaps one of the most interesting
things that you can do
one of the most interesting things you
can do is take the data and actually
calculate
how closely related are all the samples
to each other so make a giant pairwise
genetic relatedness matrix and then ask
yourself okay how many of these
uh samples from the usda collection
are clonally related they're actually
essentially genetically identical
barring some genotyping error you can
see most accessions in the collection do
not have another clone in the collection
but
about a quarter of them do they have at
least one other tree in the collection
that is named differently
that is a clone of it okay and some of
them have
multiple trees that are all actually the
same variety so in the case of
golden delicious there are 22 golden
delicious in the collection they're
15 red delicious 10 macintosh and 8
northern spy
right and you can represent that here as
a as a network
where every single dot here is an
accession in the
in the collection and a line between
them or an edge
in the network as we call it represents
a clonal relationship
so you can see that there are lots quite
a few that have one clonal relationship
two three four five six and isn't very
common but then
seven or more uh is really quite common
so
uh we see several varieties that have
seven or more and those are the popular
varieties that have
uh been propagated out and where
multiple clones exist
uh and are and are used um
so sorry
so you can do the exact same thing
instead of looking at clonal
relationships between
uh varieties you can look at first
degree relationships so either sibling
or parent offspring
so again here in panel c uh on the left
hand side here you see
each one of these nodes in the network
represents an accession in the usda
apple journalism collection
and an edge or a line between them
represents a first degree relative so
either parent offspring or sibling
so you can see we have in this histogram
on the on the right hand side
most varieties have zero like there are
many many cases where a variety does not
have a relative in the collection
but then you see many of them have one a
little bit fewer have two
first-degree relatives three four five
some of them have more than seven
uh gold and delicious and red delicious
have over 60
first-degree relatives in the collection
so when we talk about
and 15 of the usda collection
are actually related to the top eight
varieties that are grown within the
united states right now
so you've got a huge amount of
relatedness inside this over half of the
collection actually is
interrelated in a series of first-degree
relationships in this network you can
see how there's a
big clump there that is all sort of
interconnected that makes up over half
the collection
so when we say that ultimately when we
want to do genetic mapping and we want
to do it in a
in a large population of unrelated
individuals
well this is not going to happen in the
apple like all of these apples are
they're like a big extended pedigree
that you've got inside that collection
and you can quantify the degree to which
they're
related in first-degree relatives in
this manner
what's particularly interesting i find
is that uh when you look at those
first-degree relatives and you
highlight we among the varieties that
we've genotyped we have
out of the top ten we have eight of the
top 10
cultivars that are grown in terms of
acreage in the usa so
or according to the apple grower website
something or other
you got to pick some sort of source but
anyway these are top like eight
very well known widely grown varieties
in the united states
are highlighted in red those nodes and
you can see
the uh again first degree relatives are
all connected with those
edges in the network you can see that
the
there are numerous first-degree
relationships golden delicious and red
delicious again having over 60
first-degree relatives
and that 15 of the usda collection
overall is actually connected by a first
degree relative to these top eight
and that the top eight in each other
they're related to each other through a
series of first-degree relationships so
this is not
all that different from what we found in
grape as well where pinot noir and
chardonnay and you can kind of walk
through a series of first-degree
relationships down to cabernet sauvignon
and cabernet franc and
riesling and they're all kind of related
in a network of relatedness
we see the same thing in apple here and
there's one kind of
exception here up in the top right hand
corner is honeycrisp
who only has one first degree relative
in in the collection
and honeycrisp is an interesting example
uh
because what we're what we're seeing
here when we see this interrelatedness
among
cultivars it does suggest that we've you
know breeders have
made use of the tried and true tested
varieties that are successful in the
market
it makes sense to go and use those as
parents in the next generation
that's what generates a huge number of
first-degree relatives in the collection
and with honeycrisp they did when they
made the initial honey crisscross they
thought that it was a cross
between honeygold and mccown or mccoon
i'm not sure how you pronounce it
but uh and it turned out with genotyping
afterwards that neither of those were
actually the real parents of honey
crisps their
two other varieties and so uh honeycrisp
is the only
top successful cultivar here that is not
interconnected to the other ones
uh and that shares very few first-degree
relationships with other varieties in
the
in the usda collection
i suspect sean that that's going to uh
change
quickly too because thank you so much
for
uh for breeding programs now and so many
of the new releases that are coming out
of
out of breeding programs use honeycrisp
as a parent yeah and so i'm gonna i'm
gonna just break in here because we do
have a seminar
that ends um at 1 30 and and um
want to allow for at least a couple
questions and i know that students have
to move on for other classes
so um maybe we're going to leave your
concluding slide up here and people can
read through that
and just let people um either if
somebody wants to raise a hand
uh by using the little button below the
participant
pane or just uh jump in here and ask
sean a question now
hi i have a question go ahead i ask uh
with such
less genetic diversity does that affect
the nutritional value
more because they're not
bringing in new traits or does that not
have anything to do with it
yeah it's funny that you know this less
genetic diversity argument may not
really apply just because things are
related to each other
uh doesn't necessarily mean that overall
there's there's uh less genetic
diversity they haven't been
inbreeding it's not like we've been
inbreeding varieties
they are relatively closely related to
each other but they're still
extraordinarily diverse and heterozygous
um
whether that results in in less
nutritional value i think that just
needs to be measured
right i think that's a measurable thing
if anyone could actually
agree on what nutritional value uh
actually is and and how to measure it
but
that was that's that's outside of my not
my department
thank you another question
um so sean without another question
right now
maybe um if you just wanted to do any
acknowledgements
and then maybe we can just um hang out i
know that students may have to sign off
but
we can hang out for a couple few minutes
and then you have another meeting and i
want to just if everybody could give
sean a virtual
acknowledgement and thank him for his
time and sharing this data with us today
i really appreciate
what you have done and your research has
been is really fantastic
all right thank you very much for your
time i appreciate it
and sean if you do have any
acknowledgements please um share those
yeah no that's that that's it i did them
all at the front and acknowledged
everybody right up front so this is this
is it i can direct people to the website
and then to our twitter feed so if you'd
like to
learn more then you can follow us on
twitter
uh it's a lot of fun to follow sean on
twitter and he does
you know of course my interest is in the
apples but also in grapes and many other
topics as well including hemp now
i see larry's on the line so he might
want to follow john's twitter feed
there's also a very cool video on sean's
website
oh i i sorry i just thought of a
question is okay if i ask
go right ahead counter um so one thing i
was wondering is i noticed that there
were some cases where you were able to
find
loci that may be associated with
adaptation but it seemed like as you
said there weren't
like for not all the major traits there
there weren't always the super like
smoking gun like super obvious things
and i was wondering if you believe that
for many of these traits that uh
that adaptation could be polygenic and
if so like how do we actually like tell
what genes are involved in that
because i know that is polygenic you
don't always detect that in these
uh fst scans super easily
exactly yeah so if you have a a single
gene of
major effect imagine a mendelian locus
that gave a particular advantage
and it rose in frequency and showed a
strong signature of selection then that
would be very easy to detect
of course if that trait that's been
selected for
is controlled by a thousand genes uh
then you can imagine doing a genome scan
you're going to come up probably with
nothing
depending on how much power you have in
your analysis and
that's where we we essentially we lack
power
uh because we have uh we haven't
saturated the genome with markers
we don't have uh really great phenotype
data
from you know multiple individuals and
replicates and all the sorts of
things that you can imagine having in a
population of
corn or rice or something and so it does
become
more difficult to detect that kind of
polygenic selection the other thing
to consider is that there may have been
no selection right
may haven't been really much right no we
don't know
how much selection occurs in each of the
crops that we're making use of
so you know in some cases there might
not be much in other cases there may
have been intense selection for certain
traits
and so without knowing what you know
what proportion of the genome do you
actually expect to carry a signature of
selection
a priori you don't really have an a
priori
idea of how much should be under
selection so um
really what you're doing in these kinds
of analyses is looking for
the lowest hanging fruit and when you do
an analysis for example on the color
you find a really strong signature of
selection for color and so that makes a
compelling story and you've got strong
evidence that yep
color was selected for but you're more
likely to pick up color because it
happens to be controlled by
one major effect gene that mib gene and
you may not find it for things maybe
like firmness or
for other loci controlled by or other
traits controlled by too many they're
too polygenic
and you won't find that signature of
selection with the data that we
currently have
or even with really great data sets if
it's controlled by enough genes it might
be really difficult to be able to detect
so yeah you're absolutely right the
genetic architecture of the trait is
critical uh for your power and ability
to detect it in these sorts of genome
scans
anna did you still have a question
no i'm good thank you jonah did you have
a question
could i ask yeah i i do have a question
uh can i ask you real quick um my
question was
over what time scale are you really
looking at this ancestral selection
because i think we all realize now with
all these breeders that
obviously there is a lot more selection
that we see
um on specific traits so what is the
time scale of that kind of
ancient selection from the more uh less
derived varieties
right so when looking at for example the
difference between the
um the domestica and the civersia
you'd be looking all the way back to
when they shared a common ancestor
and then the same thing applies for each
of the analyses so when we're
comparing red and green apples uh what
you're looking at is the differentiation
since red and green apples diverge from
each other which might be a really long
time ago
so it's it's not really putting a time
scale on these things is a little
difficult
um but it is it is in fact in some cases
with
really great data you can do this in
terms of counting up the number of
generations
that and model it out uh that might be a
little
difficult i think in this situation with
a long-lived woody perennial that can
one of the things with apples is that
you know you can you can mate with your
great you can have an apple mate with
its great great grandparents because
there's no real
generational time uh which makes the the
relatedness networks kind of strange and
and the idea of time and generations a
little strange as well but
because you can vegetatively propagate
them for 200 years and it remains the
same individual for 200 years
so uh might be tricky it might be
possible but
i i'm not able to give real timelines
for the uh
for the the timing of the selection for
these different things but needless to
say certainly
uh that breeders have honed in a lot
more over the last 50 years on
on certain traits than uh than was the
case before and when i say breeding
you know 500 years ago it may not have
really been all that intentional
uh and it may not have been you know
making crosses and capturing pollen and
making intentional pollinations that may
have been just keeping the offspring out
of uh from
random seedlings that looked the most
desirable so
and sean somebody else um i think had a
question and that will be our last one
because you'll need a couple minutes and
then
um you have a visit with the grad
student starting at 1
40. great did somebody
have a question they wanted yes yes yes
uh here actually
and uh i have a quick question for you
sean and so you mentioned about the
knack 18
and the slips actually so what's the
nature of the
sleep this is a loss of function oh
you know yeah so we
yeah so we we're collecting gbs data so
uh
we get whatever snip happens to land
nearby and is probably
in ld with the functional allele that's
what we always assume
but that snip actually happens to be a
non-synonymous
snip in the in a binding domain of the
neck gene that's described in that plant
genome paper
so it may be functional but we've done
some additional sequencing of knack and
it turns out there's all sorts of
variation in knack that could be
functional that is linked to that d5y
mutation
and we're going to do a more
comprehensive sequencing of that entire
gene across a large
number of accessions plug that genotype
data back into the gwas and see which
which of the markers is really most
strongly associated uh with the uh
with the phenotype um there's also like
a huge deletion right in the middle of
one of the domains too so it could be
a presence absence variation a copy
number variation or
a structural variation going on within
that gene so we're going to try to tease
that out with a little more additional
sequencing but
to date no the causal allele that that
locus is not known
cool thanks sean and um boy
you know if it was up to me i would just
say this is the rest of our day and we
just keep you on the line
but i know you have other appointments
for the afternoon and
other people have other activities so
again everybody
thank you um thank join me in thanking
sean for
his time and his um his sharing his
expertise and his research with us today
thank you thanks folks thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu